Speaker 1: when we talk about consequences for
perpetuating the lie that Donald Trump actually
won the 2020 election, that Joe Biden actually
stole the 2020 election. One group of people that
participated in that is attorneys, attorneys
filing bogus lawsuits, and we have some nice
news. A judge has ordered pro-Trump attorneys
who brought a frivolous election fraud case
to pay more than $180000 to defendants that they
sued Caitlin Polenz, writing about this for CNN.
Two lawyers who went to court to claim voter fraud
after the 2020 election must pay nearly 180 grand
to the defendants. The judge wrote that their
lawsuit aimed to manipulate gullible members of
the public and foment public unrest. These are
attorneys you may not be familiar with. This is
not Lin Wood, Rudy Giuliani, Sidney Powell,
Jenna Ellis. This is attorneys Gary Fielder
and Ernest John Walker. They are going to have
to pay attorney's fees of 50 grand to Facebook,
now known as Metta $63000 to Dominion Voting
Systems, $63000 to the nonprofit Center for
Tech and Civic Life. 6000 to the state of
Pennsylvania, 5000 to the state of Michigan,
the judge near Reiter wrote in his order. They
need to take responsibility for their misconduct.
I believe that rather than a legitimate
use of the legal system to seek redress
for redress of grievances, this lawsuit has been
used to manipulate gullible members of the public
and foment public unrest. To that extent, this
lawsuit has been an abuse of the legal system and
an interference with the machinery of government
for all these reasons. I feel that a significant
sanctions award is merited. This is fantastic.
It's one thing to see them laughed out of court
told as they were with was at 63 lawsuits that
there is no merit, that it's not going to go
forward, that the judge is going to put a stop
to it. That is good. But at a certain point, if
it doesn't hit them in the pocketbook proverbial
pocketbook, it doesn't really disincentivize them
from doing this again. And we have a legal
system where if there is merit, they will,
they will be allowed to carry this forward.
There was absolutely no merit here. The lawsuit
from late December was an attempt to create
a class action challenge on behalf of voters,
including eight plaintiffs. NARRATOR wrote a
scathing 68 page opinion condemning the lawsuit.
The plaintiffs had no lawyers or experts able
to support their claims of switched votes and
government conspiracies. The judge noted, calling
the lawsuit itself one enormous conspiracy theory.
You will also recall that in August, a federal
judge in Michigan sanctioned pro-Trump lawyer
Sidney Powell and Lin Wood, who I mentioned
earlier, and other attorneys ordering them
to reimburse the attorney's fees that the City
of Detroit and Michigan state officials paid.
The judge said the lawyers who worked on Trump
aligned lawsuits seeking to challenge election
results, had engaged in litigation practices
that were abusive and in turn sanctionable.
These people have to be held accountable. They
have to be held accountable because they are
going to do this again and we don't have to.
Guess at whether they will do it again, they're
telling us that they will do it again. They
told us before the Virginia gubernatorial race
that it looked like there was already fraud. Glenn
Youngkin ultimately won, but if Glenn Youngkin
had lost, they were going to do it again. We know
that they have been explicit in saying We're going
to keep going with this. They don't really want
solutions to the problem they claim exists. They
want to use claims of voter fraud as a cudgel, as
a mallet of sorts to beat the public over the head
when an election doesn't actually go their way.
And there need to be consequences. And this is an
excellent decision. We'll see if they actually
pay the money. Want to remind everybody of a
couple of things? We are going to be off tomorrow,
Thursday as well as Friday for the Thanksgiving
federal holiday here in the United States. I know
that most of our American viewers know about this,
but I always get dozens and dozens of emails
from around the world. David, sir. Where are you?
And it is Thanksgiving. We will be off for the
rest of the week. Also, we've scheduled the next
David Pakman Show Viewer Town Hall. It's going
to be on December 14th at 6:00 p.m. Eastern Time.
It will be number one open to anybody who wants to
call in, but priority will be given to our website
members so you can get yourself signed up at
join Packman dot com if you want a better chance
to talk to me on the 14th. The entire event
will stream live for whoever wants to watch it.
It will be exclusively on the Pacman Live YouTube
channel. That's YouTube.com slash Pacman Live. It
won't be on our main YouTube channel. It won't
be on Twitch. It won't be on Facebook. It'll be
exclusively on the Pacman Live YouTube channel.
So that's December 14th. And of course, you can
sign up on our web. Join Pacman dot com, become a
member, and as a member, you will also get access
to today's bonus show in which I will tell you
my Thanksgiving plans. Very boring. But producer
Pat will tell us his Thanksgiving plans are very,
very exciting. All right, we'll take a quick break
and be back right after this. Remember that the
David Pakman show is primarily made possible by
viewers and listeners like you through our
membership program. You can sign up at Join
Packman Gqom members get instant access to The
Daily Bonus Show, an extra show we produce just
for you. You also get commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show priority handling during
our viewer town halls, the next of which is going
to be on December 14th at 6:00 PM Eastern Time.